you need to begin with your diagram I
know they supply a diagram to you by
which I mean I supplied a diagram to you
but the act of creating a diagram it's
critical to knowing what's going on okay
so humor me give me your own brain and
bring yourself up diagram he's where
we're at hmm a straight section of a
remark three but it's three kilometers
wide so that gives us well my River is
not going to spec if you get the idea
and I have a few points here right I
have H which is where I'm trying to get
to
I have be the portion where I start I
have a point directly opposite and then
I have P a point in between the directly
opposite point and my destination that I
could Row two and then do the walk from
there okay I have some totals I have
attended along others all the way along
the shore there and very helpfully they
hold your head an incredible amount of
this question right they even give you
the variable P R and say call that X and
then the pots that ensued they walk you
through the process of trying to craft a
solution to this right part one state
the expression for the length of pH just
stay okay I'm even gonna be so lazy I'm
gonna just on my diet right if this is
10 and take your way X which is that
difference there I think this is going
to be 10 takeaway X okay I'll put that
moving color 10 take my eggs kilometers
you can see where these are all going to
come in right part to show the total
time T hours taken by jury to reach his
destination is and then they give you
this result okay so for instance you can
see the 10 minus X that we just
determined it appears in the result
we're about to try and prove it's
divided by five why is it divided by 5
that's speed right that's the speed so
at some point because
to show a question at some point I would
expect you to say something like what am
i after distance is speed times time or
you know there's many different
combinations of this right you need to
show that relationship somehow because
otherwise you're 10 minus X on five it
just literally a piece from in air but
you must show this right now this is
legitimate this is okay right so for
instance I could say off of the basis of
this for this little interval pH from pH
I'm going to make this statement about
that particular interval right the
distance is 10 take away X the speed is
5 and the time is well I don't know what
the time is we'll call it team if
they've given me no that's capital T I'm
trying to find so this is just a
personal one of 41 I suppose all right
so from this that's how I can make the
statement therefore T y equals 10 take
away X on five it doesn't come from
nowhere
okay that's critically important
likewise I need to get the time for this
distance right so how are we gonna do
that
what are we appeal to what geometry do
we appeal to we appeal to pi riders
right not the east right angle already
given to you on the diagram right you
already know this is three should by
Pythagoras what is this length here
square root of XY plus 9 or based on I
think the way that they're asking for it
9 plus X square
that's fine so in the same way here I
would say like why is or similarly for
this distance beeping I'm going to make
exactly the same statement with the
different distance and the different
speed okay so I'm going to say here's my
distance
sorry equals speed times time except my
speed is different now because I am
rather a slower drama than a water okay
I've been able this different time
because they haven't given me any games
for this but I know it's different to
this one right
so therefore 2 u 2 equals the square
root so from there T is just the sum of
those times right it's reasonable to say
okay if I want the total time I've got a
transfer here and then DPR right
therefore T equals t1 plus t2 and the
next line is the result that they've
asked for right so the dot is required
okay this is a this is too much right to
bollocks one mark to mark if what you
have in here is briefed on that I don't
know if you've actually shown what's
going on right it seems kind of obvious
just take this right but then again what
else are they asking you to show so be
careful about how you were actually
working on you put out okay
part three again they're super holding
your hand they say this is the question
you're asking jack right what values
connects take what kinds connects them
okay now strictly speaking egg can be
anything you like X could even and I'm
sort of stretching the definitions you
it could even be negative okay if this
is X here then I guess negative x would
go this way okay however it's kind of
pointless right it's kind of pointless
because if X is negative I'm going
further away from ever getting any
closer a chat all right so therefore I
could exclude it quite easily from the
domain so the closest I would get to
here is just straight across
well value when X - this straight to a
be 0 right now in the same way my
alternative is telling you well touch is
but I think a sorry X bigger and then
I'd be good straight there if I went
straight to H by Rhodey what would the
value next big it would be ten now again
just playing game it could be bigger for
what's to twelve or fifteen or twenty
but again it's not what's the point
I'm doing pause edge and then doubling
back that's clearly not within the
domain I'm actually interested in okay
so all you really need to stay is that 0
is less than X is less than 10 it's just
a statement it's just about okay
so that's where I got that from I got it
from this diagram and they don't ask you
to supply any more reasoning for what